hey guys it's inka so for the next 24
hours
i will only be eating foods that are the
color
purple a lot of people have been doing
this on youtube it's a very
popular format that i also wanted to try
for myself to not just experiment
it's also just a cool way for you guys
to find out what there is out there
that's edible
and is purple so i picked purple because
i wanted a little bit of a challenge but
not so much that i'd be starving myself
i'm actually going to try
and stay away from anything that's
artificially colored
has to be naturally colored purple
which kind of just makes my job harder
than it already
is so the next step is
to go to the grocery store and
see what we can find for breakfast lunch
and dinner that is
purple all right let's go these are
rainbow carrots they have purple ones so
i'm gonna keep these and of course
there's grapes
i feel like figs might be purple
eggplant purple red onions
rebel cabbage they're going in here too
blueberries and savory foods i think
these are the first potato chips
this is black but it's actually purple
fruit juice
that should be purple right it's brown
this looks pretty purple to me even
though it says blue there's this
huge bag of just different kinds of
purple things
now to plan out my meals for tomorrow i
made it back home with my
giant bag of groceries i also changed
into a purple shirt i'm just going to
take everything out now to see
what i have just to show you guys what
we're working with this is everything i
bought from the store
i also have purple noodles i think are
made with like purple yam
and then i also have this indigo punch
tea this is butterfly pea flour in it if
we add
like lemon juice or lime juice it
becomes purple so i thought that would
be a good drink i think we have a good
balance
of protein fruits vegetables
and carbs i i i haven't really planned
out my meals yet
but yeah so we have a lot of food here
and let's start it off with breakfast
this is my kitchen
because it's new york city it's pretty
small i'm gonna try to make this work
i'm picking out all of the fruits that i
bought blueberries
grapes plums and figs we also already
have this blue machine smoothie that's
actually purple
but i figured i could just make my own
so
smoothie building time it's light
different shades of purple here's our
blender
dump these all in i'm gonna pour some of
this smoothie in there too
look at that purple just to amp it up i
have my blueberry
chia jam super purple and now
to blitz it
what do you guys think is this purple
under this light it looks a little bit
more purple
so i think this is now drinkable custom
fruit up this is what we have you guys
we have the plums on top we have the
grapes fake is like kind of wrinkly here
that looks pretty purple right i'm just
gonna go ahead and try this now
to me it really just looks like a normal
like blueberry
smoothie bowl so i guess you really
could make
a smoothie bowl out of purely purple
foods i'll just be here finishing this
then i'll see you guys at work for
lunch we have catered lunch day i'm
going to try and see if we can find
purple foods
if that was purple hair if i can't find
any purple foods i'm going to have to
cook my own so
let's see if we can find some salad i
don't see any that's red
[Music]
so because we couldn't find anything out
there i'm just going to try
and make my own lunch good thing i
brought some stuff with me this is what
i have
the red onions carrots they didn't
really have that many
purple carrots but i tried to pick some
out and then i have the octopus
i know this is kind of intimidating
maybe for people who haven't had it
before
but it's actually really good and then
we have the purple yam noodles
a nice light purple i would say i didn't
have a sauce
but because it came into the tasty space
i actually found this red wine sauce
that tasty producer elvin was making
that is actually
purple so i guess we have a sauce down
i'm just going to toss these in there
and let it cook and while that's cooking
i'm just going to cut
some of this onion and the carrots up
noodles
are now cooked kind of a pinkish purple
i have the onions cut up
and the carrots and we have the octopus
we toss it into the pan the purple
carrots actually end up having like
orange bits in them i think it's
smelling pretty good so far with onions
i feel like just have a stronger flavor
than yellow or white onions the octopus
is actually already cooked i just
figured we'd give it a little bit more
flavor
and add the noodles in
this is looking really purple i don't
really know what i was expecting
but this is pretty freaking awesome
it's so purple more onions and
carrots that's our very purple looking
dish this actually turned out to look a
lot better than i thought it was going
to
super excited to taste this but before
that a
purple drink so this butterfly pea
flower it's a flower that just turns
liquid into this natural blue color
add my hot water
can you see the color i didn't even need
to add lemon because i think
this tea already has some raspberry and
apple bits in it
i guess i already have a purple drink
purple tea purple pasta it smells really
good
so hopefully that means it actually is
really good
so pumped
wow i don't think i've ever had things
that are this
vividly colored that isn't like you know
artificial
wow that is actually that's actually
really good i think it's because the
sauce is really good
i can't believe we were actually able to
make this work all right trans to you
too
[Music]
i have to show you guys how pretty the
purple actually is look at this color
i didn't even have to add anything else
to it this turned out so good now i feel
a little more confident about dinner i
gotta get a second taste
tester ta-da
it's so purple it was with your red wine
sauce if it looked purple then that
means i did it right
it's good right right my sauce is really
low oh my god okay
i'm about to take a snack break to eat
my chips have my tea here
but ashley is giving me really weird
looks i don't get it but
i support you always it's just a
butterfly pizza with lemon
no it's not it's natural what is in your
hand
what is this face i like it it's good
it's a little thicker
and very purple like for sure
[Music]
i'm on my way back home it's still light
outside but i'm really hungry
we're just gonna see what we can make
with the food we bought we have the
purple cabbage eggplant this is the
leftover onion red onion from
lunch this is really cool this is purple
shiso leaf so i got them from an event i
went to earlier they're green on the
other side but
this side is purple there's also the
squid
pretty purple looking i also just love
squid
so this worked out perfectly for me can
you guys see how the water is actually
purple here's all the vegetables i have
i'm just going to stir fry it now
i'm also just snacking on this while i'm
waiting i'm a big sweet potato person
normally
so i think that's why i'm really loving
this i feel healthier too while i'm
eating this even though it's probably
all just in my head there's a lot of
sugar on this
it looks healthier than a normal potato
chips
can't forget the black rice i know it
says black
it actually is purple i also just eat
this a lot normally
this is the one i have at home this is
what just the black rice looks like you
could cook this as
is too but it would just be a little too
coarse when you mix it with white rice
it looks like this
just gonna pop that in the microwave
this is what it kind of looks like now
thinking of putting it in this onigiri
mold i have
add these squid rings they're already
cooked so
this is my purple dinner i know there's
a lot of white
here this part is purple it's probably
as purple as it gets
without artificial dyes dinner is served
yeah i don't really know what i made but
i think this looks pretty purple
and then i also had some of the tea left
over from earlier i just made that into
an iced version
i don't normally cook with eggplant this
like turned out kind of brown
this is a pretty purple mouthful
here's a squid i should show you guys
the purple side
even though there's no sauce to go with
it i still love it i love how chewy it
is i just love it
that it's a purple food because i get to
eat it on this challenge
i think the fact that i'm also really
hungry probably also makes this really
good
wrap this in tada
the shisho flavor is super strong this
is really good
i've always loved adding black rice to
white rice i kind of like the
extra like texture i'm so satisfied
right now i think i love the color
purple even more now
this video is basically just me eating
for 24 hours do i have dessert oh my god
so i do actually have a purple dessert
even though i don't think there's gonna
be stomach space for it but maybe in
like
i don't know two hours three so it was
my birthday last week and two of my
friends bought me
this amazing ube cake that i actually
already ate
some of ube is also just like a
naturally like really beautiful purple
color
this cake is like super vibrant oh my
gosh it's just gonna fall right over but
this is what it looks like
oh it's so soft can we get a perfect
slice yes
okay guys i gotta let you guys see what
this looks like
ta-da look at that
purple it has some cream in the middle
but otherwise i think this is probably
the most purple of purple desserts
this is a huge bite oh yeah i don't
normally look for ube but ube flavor in
this
is like perfect almost like a coconutty
taste
no i can't stop eating this pick so this
challenge actually turned out to be
really fun
i think there was definitely more things
that i expected that were actually
purple
let me know what color i should try to
eat for 24 hours
i'll be here finishing this cake
hey guys what's up it's inka and for the
next 24 hours
i will only be eating yellow food last
time i did
only purple foods for 24 hours it turned
out better than expected so i
asked you guys what color you wanted me
to do next based on the comments i got i
think it's safe to say that
yellow has won by far so
yellow foods it is same as last time i'm
gonna try to maintain
a very very balanced diet we're gonna
find food that
is naturally yellow but this time before
we go shopping i'm actually gonna look
through my pantry and my fridge to see
if i can find anything that's yellow
and we can start from there i was
thinking that
i wouldn't be able to find that many
yellow foods but it turns out
plastic is yellow i have my yellow
carrots
and my yellow baby carrots from last
time cheese is also yellow i mean
different shades of yellow lemons
eggs and garlic but since we're
preparing for three meals it's probably
a good idea to stop by the grocery store
anyways so
let's go shopping here we go
[Music]
definitely need that golden melon
we have so much fruit yellow peppers
our first vegetable i found these
pumpkin noodles they look pretty yellow
to me
pickled radish they're super good with
noodles some more fruit
golden kiwi and maple this is just
flying
fish it's yellow
this car is so yellow right now
[Music]
it is time to make some breakfast i
don't have anything in my wardrobe
that's yellow but
i have my gudetama socks on i also have
this little guy sitting in the
background
people don't know who gudetama is he is
a lazy egg we'll be eating him today
i also have this on my fridge i'm
clearly just trying to find things that
are yellow to fit today's theme
breakfast time let's do it for breakfast
i usually eat either
different kinds of fruits or make a
smoothie sometimes i have toast and eggs
because we bought a bunch of fruit at
the grocery store i was thinking of just
making a platter
of mixed yellow fruits and then also
making
an egg dish to go with it i would need
the golden kiwi pineapple
mango golden apple golden honeydew
i'm just going to cut these all up and
i'll make the eggs on the side
yellow meeting for some sweetness what
i'm trying to make
is tamagoyaki a japanese style omelette
i don't have the actual pans so we're
gonna try to do it
in this little round pan of mine i
actually also
did them in my bento box video i just
never had
to do them one-handed so i'm gonna put
the camera down and not
screw this up all right guys breakfast
is ready
this is our yellow breakfast for today
the
melon didn't turn out to be that yellow
i think it was just the skin
the kiwi is looking a little bit on the
greener side the eggs turned out pretty
good they were like a pale yellow
they would have probably been more
yellow if i only if i used more yolks
it's like sweet and savory i love that
what this has made me realize is that
there
are so many different kinds of fruits
that are yellow and they're all like
really sweet which is not a bad thing
i had no idea golden apples existed it's
really cool to know that i'm able to
sort of
eat what i normally have for breakfast
anyways even on this challenge
so i still have a few minutes before
work and i was thinking
at one of the coffee shops that i
normally go to they have this drink
called the turmeric latte that is yellow
so i want to go check that out before we
head to the office
here it is this is the turmeric latte it
is now a pale
yellow color i've never actually had
turmeric before um
so i don't know how this is gonna go
it's like super aromatic a sort of kick
to it
it's actually not bad that's my yellow
drink all right now back to work
there's no caterer lunch today so i'm
going to be making my own lunch
but i forgot to bring my pasta
so i'm gonna see if i can find pasta
here
in the tasty space boom i have my eggs
the yellow pepper i have parmesan and
butter
i was thinking we can make a carbonara
of some sort
vegetarian style in terms of our pasta
problem alvin
donated some homemade pasta this pasta
dough
is super yellow i'm assuming he only put
egg yolks in here
that's perfect i will have to roll it
out now and then we can go from
there
i have my pasta strip now to roll it oh
nice nice
nice here's a pasta strip tada
now we're going to run it on the other
side
here's our fettuccine this is going to
be the longest lunch break i've ever had
i think this is good enough for one
portion so i'm just gonna leave this
here now
pasta is a-okay i'm gonna cut this
pepper up
and make the egg and cheese sauce
sing this in peppers are done i'm gonna
set this aside
these are just the egg yolks and cheese
we'll just mix this together okay pasta
is done
put this in here just tossing this
together add a little bit more water
our little yellow paste oh yeah there we
go
here it is eat carbonara
normally i would put black pepper on
this but we did say yellow challenge so
yellow pasta it is eating time this
smells really good
oh yeah it's not bad this is still
really creamy
the yellow pepper kind of pulled through
too in terms of sauce this was literally
just egg yolks and
parmesan very yellow if you say that
it's good because your pasta
doll is good i'm gonna shut this video
down
the pepper do you know what flavor froyo
we have right now
is it yellow it's light yellow we have a
froyo machine today's flavor is hawaiian
pineapple
see if it really is yellow i got some
froyo
it really is a light yellow i was
thinking i'm gonna cut some
bananas up and put that on here too
pineapple folio with banana
there's so many yellow things super
refreshing but yeah
lunch was a great success
there's cookies not sugar cookies yellow
i don't know
it's kind of like yellow food you can't
have any of that
yeah i can have it no cookies for me
snack break
and i have my honey butter chips also
totally forgot
that i had durian chips i'm gonna be
feasting a little bit my yellow water
bottle
these are super good canis is yellow
oh my god i forgot how good these were i
know a lot of people don't like durian
but
it's actually one of my favorite fruits
the big chunk freeze dried
it's unlike anything i've ever had in my
life
truly i'm on my way home raw summer
groceries figured i could make a curry
hopefully it works out ready to get some
things chopped up yellow squash that i
just bought
yellow carrots corn i was actually
thinking i would put some apple in this
too
add a little bit of sweetness and then
we of course have the
topico it actually kind of smells like
lemon
zesty i'll just top it off with this
ginger and garlic they're both like a
pale yellow
yellow pickled radish which will also be
a side dish pumpkin noodles this would
go well
with this curry soup which i made
actually
yesterday i would add a little bit more
tumeric on it because that's what gives
it more of a golden hue
let's try to put this together the
noodles are about done
that's a solid yellow color
this is looking good i'm just gonna
assemble everything really quickly
and then we'll be good for dinner
i hope you guys are ready for this
because i really think this is as yellow
as it gets
ready and tada
everything sort of came together you see
the radish the topico
that's the yellow squash and the carrot
golden apple corn
mini stir fry i sort of really just like
threw everything yellow
together let's give this a try smells
like curry
i don't really taste the pumpkin i want
to try some of that fish roll
i love these normally eat these with
rice but they're good like this too
pretty good well i'm really hungry we
have
the vegetables we have fruits we have
protein we have carbs
i think we have a pretty balanced meal
here just finishing up some dishes now
i have a lot of dishes to clean i'm
gonna do some work
and then probably time for dessert i got
a little carried away with work it is
now
around like 10 p.m but
i made my dessert pineapple ice with
star fruit frozen pineapple pineapple
bits
and ice super creamy here you see the
star
fruit it is shaped like a star i grew up
with these so
it was really cool being able to find
them here so it's kind of sour it's very
very tart the last meal of today here we
go prime brain freeze material i think
today went pretty well there's a lot of
yellow food out
there let me know if you guys want me to
do this again leave a comment below
and based on what i get that will be the
next color i do
otherwise peace and see you guys next
time
hey guys it's zinka and i'm gonna be
eating black foods
for 24 hours so we're doing this again
i've done purple color
yellow color and this time because of
popular demand
i am doing black foods again this is a
frame that has been done by a lot of
youtubers
like kristen and saffron just like
before we are not going to do anything
that's artificially colored
everything i eat must be naturally black
i know black isn't exactly the most
appetizing color but i think i'll be
able to find some things that might
change your mind it's going to take me a
while
to source these black foods i'm going to
go to multiple grocery stores and from
there i'll plan my meals around that
i'm excited let's do this walk around
the store trying to find back stuff and
this is what i found
black himalayan salt a bunch of black
truffles here it's kind of expensive so
maybe not
i found this black truffle sauce it's a
little less expensive so i think we're
gonna go with this
dark soy sauce i'm gonna go with this
one premium dark soy sauce black fungus
found two kinds of black rice i'm gonna
get both
getting some seaweed really quick black
sesame powder black bean garlic sauce
found these super cute panda ice cream
bars but
i think they're they have a lot of white
so i won't be able to do it
preserve duck eggs
i really wasn't expecting to find this
here but we have some
black chicken so i'm excited to cook
with this good morning
so it is now breakfast time i have my
black shirt on
i only have two things in mind for
breakfast i'm gonna show you guys
right now i have blackberries and then i
also have black soybeans i am going to
turn this
into soy milk using my soy milk maker
this is the soy beans after they're
soaked so this has been soaking
overnight this
is my soy milk maker i use it a lot
because i love soy milk the process is
actually
super fast what it's essentially doing
is just heating it up grinding it up
about maybe half an hour later we're
going to have soy milk this is now done
what color is it oh it's a great color
i guess the beans turned out more gray
in the end i am going to grab my
sesame powder and breakfast is done i
kept it super simple really just the
blackberries
and the soy milk here's the black sesame
soy milk it's definitely
a lot lighter than you would think after
the process
it went from this to a much lighter
color
black sesame also helped a little bit
but that being said i think this is a
pretty typical breakfast for me
blackberries are always good going to
give this a try it smells super black
sesame
ish yeah that's good the black sesame
definitely adds like a nutty texture i
am pretty pleased
i think the day is starting off pretty
well gonna finish this up
and catch you guys at the office it's
now lunch time
and i'm back here in the tasty kitchen
figured i would
make just a four ingredient pasta dish
found a couple of items that i think we
can throw together and make it work and
show you guys what i have
black squid ink pasta the hawaiian black
salt which i have never seen before
black truffle sauce totally bought the
black truffle sauce because
i don't think we have enough in our
budget to actually buy
real truffles and then we have black
garlic
comes in like this brown shape and then
when you peel it off
there's that black garlic bulb inside
which looks like this
it really is just aged garlic the
texture of it
is really sticky i've never had this
before this is gonna be really
interesting
the flavor is supposed to be more mild
than garlic but it smells
stronger so i'm just gonna really
quickly chop up the black garlic right
now
got the water boiling here let's get to
work oh
it's so squishy guys this is so
interesting it looks like candy almost i
don't know what that means
but i hope it's still gonna taste good
salt this quickly pasta is now done
we're now going to put the garlic in
here we go
oh i don't want to burn it it's getting
smoky it smells good though
it looks a little bit like mushrooms at
this point the smell of it
is like super fragrant it's a really
nice smell
it's looking super dark so that's cool
i'm gonna add the truffle sauce which
smells so good
[Music]
lastly just a sprinkle of salt it's time
for the grand reveal
tada it's
super dark let me try to find a garlic
but
that's what the black garlic looks like
now i'm gonna add some black pepper on
there
okay so this is my black coffee uh which
is normally how i drink coffee actually
let's give this a taste
black i know doesn't really look that
appetizing usually but
i have high hopes
oh i just got a huge bite of the black
garlic
oh the black garlic is it's super chewy
think of like a gummy candy the squid
ink pasta is good
it's really just like normal pasta i
don't normally
uh eat black truffle i'm not that bougie
but the black truffle sauce is nice i
feel like an elevated mushroom sauce
overall not bad for a plate of complete
darkness this is definitely a good way
to balance it out
i wonder if this is going to make my
tongue black nope
not yet as per usual i'm going to finish
this up
and then i'll see you guys for the next
meal alva just told me that he left some
cookies
on my desk that i should be able to eat
on this challenge so i'm going back to
my desk here
they are smells really good
this is so dark it's an actual black
cookie
he did say that this is made from 100
cocoa
so i think that means i can eat it
this is actually really good it's like
kind of bittersweet
more so than like a normal chocolate
cookie that's my snack for the day
thank you so it's after work i found a
boba tea place
on instagram that sells this really cool
looking black colored
boba drink so i'm gonna go there with a
couple of friends
and check it out
i'm here with my friends i have friends
this is what the drink looks like
there's boba grass jelly and i think
this is like a cocoa
foam there's a lot of white in here so
i'm gonna try and mix it together and
see if it's gonna turn
more black it didn't do anything can i
still drink this
yeah yeah i think that's fine good the
cocoa is very interesting it tastes like
chocolate milk if you add a little bit
of
grass jelly to it it's like oreo
this does taste like oreo it's like oreo
in a drink so for dinner we have a bunch
of things
black rice and then there's wild rice
and i already cooked it in my rice
cooker
as you guys can see oh woody or mushroom
which ends up after you soak it looking
like this
black bean garlic sauce the dark soy
sauce this is the
century old egg that a lot of people are
scared of and then we also have seaweed
black fish roll i honestly wasn't
expecting to find this at all but
kind of like what happened with the
truffle can't exactly afford caviar so
this is a good substitute
i'm also realizing there's a lot of
really expensive stuff that's black huh
well here's our caviar for the night
then i also have
chicken soup cooking in the background
which my roommate started for me earlier
because it takes
two and a half hours just based on what
we have i'm thinking i'll probably end
up making something like a sushi roll i
don't really want to call it sushi
because it's really just
me trying to mesh all the ingredients
together then we'll have chicken soup on
the side i'm just cutting up the woodier
mushrooms even though they're called
mushrooms they're more like
you know jelly and super rubbery and
slippery
when you bite into it it's more like a
crunchy chewy texture
this is what the preserved duck egg
looks like it smells
super pungent and i think they like
challenge people to eat this like on
survivor or something but it's really
not that scary
i grew up eating this in like rice
porridge congee we call it
it does smell very strong though i will
say it does but don't let that keep you
away
this is what it looks like on the inside
[Music]
it's super black right now the only
thing about cooking black food is that
you don't know
like what if i actually burnt it i have
my rice
it turned out fluffier than i had
expected
to i have my preserved duck egg and
woody mushroom then i have my
tobiko let's try this
i am going to now roll this up to my
best to the best of my abilities
my makeshift sushi mat so i have my
sushi roll
i'm just going to cut it now and plate
it and then it will be
done alright guys dinner is served
tada and here's the chicken
okay the food is literally so dark that
the camera doesn't know where it is
boom i put the black tobiko on top of it
this is just a smear of like a soy sauce
a thicker soy sauce
i tried to make it fancier because it
looks like caviar even though it's not
caviar you guys have to see this
look at this drumstick that's all
natural you guys my roommate made this
into a soup but i took out the soup
because
the soup is brown in taiwan they make
chicken soup with
black chicken sometimes it's really good
for your body that's what my mom told me
growing up so
i believe it i also have my soy milk
from earlier
that's what it looks like looks
appetizing i'm gonna try the one with
the fish roll
because it looks like fancy sushi
there's like crunchy bits in there both
from the woodyear mushroom and the
fish roll the facials salty it adds a
lot of flavor the black bean garlic
sauce is really coming through this
one's really good
it really isn't as terrifying as it
looks i try the chicken
it's super tender it's super interesting
too look
the meat is like gray look at this the
skin is completely black
meat is super tender it's literally
falling off this has also been cooking
for like
three hours oh it's super good with the
soy sauce wow
i think out of like all the one color
challenges i've done this might be my
favorite meal so far
guys these are so great i'm super
satisfied let me know what color you
guys
think i should do next leave a comment
below otherwise see you guys next time
hey guys it's inka and this time
i will only be eating pink colored foods
for 24 hours
i was scrolling through the comments and
i saw a lot of people
requesting for pink and so that's why
i decided to go with pink this time so i
know i mentioned doing clear colored
foods and that's still going to happen
i just have something really special
planned for that episode so
please look out for it please be patient
coming back to today
as always we will be trying to find food
that is
naturally colored pink i can't really
think of
too many pink things the first thing
that comes to mind is cotton candy which
is not exactly the most
natural i would do my best to find some
protein
some carbs and some veggies and fruits
that are pink so wish me luck
and let's go grocery shopping again
i don't know i found this radish thing
bacon's usually still pink it really
isn't a lot of pink here
um i'm not really sure what to do so
i'm just scavenging pink salt
real strawberry juice and puree these
pink green rice cakes look really good
sakura and put this over something and
also grabbing these
crab chips before doing cheese spread
found some pink grapefruit
it is a brand new pink day
i don't really have any like super pink
shirts
but i do have this coral pink uh
top that hopefully will pass for today
so let's get started with breakfast
there's not really that much
for this first meal three things this is
a pink grapefruit so it should be
a lot more pinker and sweeter than
normal grapefruit and then we have the
strawberry yogurt i really like this
brand
because they're usually a lot less sweet
and
they focus on using really simple
ingredients
and then i'm just going to cook up some
bacon
and then we can plate everything
together
it's definitely a lot lighter in color
i'm trying to keep it more pink so it's
kind of really greasy
and then over here i'm realizing the
yogurt it's a super light pink
i'm going to pour it out and maybe add a
raspberry
to make it a little more pink and
breakfast is done we have the bacon
we have the pink grapefruit um here's
the yogurt
on camera i feel like it doesn't look as
pink but it's definitely not your usual
red
slightly sweeter than ruby grapefruits
and then for this bacon
it's definitely very floppy i don't mind
it honestly
still good to finish off we have this
strawberry yogurt
i guess now it's strawberry and
raspberry get a big
heaping spoonful this is perfect
just to get my caffeine fix in i was
thinking of stopping by one of my
favorite cafes here in new york they're
known actually for this
really pretty drink called the rose
petal milk tea really excited to take
you guys there
so i'm going to finish up clean up and
then be on my way
[Music]
this is all like naturally colored rose
syrup and these are
little flower petals
i'm just gonna be here for a little more
before i
head to the office this is my pink drink
of the day
it is now lunch time i'm back here at
the
tasty kitchen we have a bunch of
assorted items
this is what we have in total pancetta
and prosciutto
both of which are ready to eat so we
have the pink radish
and berry juice and then we have our
spices pink
salt and pink peppercorns two different
kinds of spreads
one is this port wine cheese spread
which is i think pink because
of the wine and then we have this it's
called tara masala
made with lemon juice olive oil and
fresh
fish roll it just looked really
interesting and i was really surprised
to find out that there's no pink color
dye in this so i'm excited to
test this out and then in terms of carbs
i enlisted elvin's help again
and that's why on this side we will find
this pink crepe batter look at how
nicely pink it is so the pink hair
actually comes from beets
uh like a beet puree i am excited to
work with this so we can do some sort of
prosciutto radish crepe
situation this meal really is going to
be a bit of an adventure
i am going to start making the crepes
first
normally with crepes i use butter
but because butter is not pink i'm
hoping this non-stick pan will work
okay i'm not going to lie it looks like
a giant piece of ham
but but once we plate it
it will probably look better this is
what it looks like it really does look
like him but that's a pretty
cool looking crepe right
the crepes are done i am now
gonna move on to these pink peppercorns
i'm going to try and crush them a little
bit
using this
it almost smells floral we'll see how it
tastes we don't even have to cook
anything else because they're all ready
to eat my plan
for the prosciutto pancetta and the
radish is to
kind of roll them up and wrap them
together i see them do this at like
cocktail parties usually it's around
breadsticks but
this could be the healthier version okay
so these are done
just open this port wine cheese i really
don't think i've ever had anything like
this before
wine and cheese usually go together so i
guess this makes sense
oh not exactly the consistency i was
expecting it's kind of really
goopy smells like fish roll i am just
going to spread these on the crepes now
multiple parts completed so i'm just
gonna throw them all in a plate
and we should be ready for lunch here is
lunch these crepes actually do look like
meat but i promise they're actually
crepes
and then we have the filling in between
the prosciutto and pancetta wrapped
around
radish with pink peppercorn
and pink salt on top also
i have this drink it's actually mostly
water with
one drop of a hibiscus tea now it's pink
time to eat actually gonna work on one
of these
first it smells good
i actually wouldn't mind having that as
an appetizer they actually pair together
pretty well
it's kind of like that sweet savory
combo prosciutto they usually pair it
with melon
in this case the daikon is the sweetness
in that pairing and the peppercorn adds
a nice touch
this might just be something that i
would snack on at home
even though there's only one drop of
hibiscus in here you can still taste it
i think this is the one with
cheese you definitely get the aged
cheddar kind of like cheese
on bread crepe is good i'm really
excited about this fish roll
spread interesting i think i like
the cheese one a little more the fish
hits you right away it almost like
catches me off guard but it's not like
bad i think lunch turned out to be
better than i expected
going to now finish it up
and get back to work it's around 4 30
right now
i think it's a good time to crack open
this bag of chips these are those crab
shrimp chips that i found should hold me
through until
dinner this is actually really thick i
guess it comes from the crab and the
shrimp
this is what it looks like it really
just tastes like
shrimp chips which i love so i'm here
with inca what are you eating
pink chips on brand for today
please try these are the chips pink
these are definitely you like it
i'm back home it's still pretty early
but i think
because of the limited amount of pink
foods i've been able to find
i haven't been eating that much so it's
all like digesting very quickly so
i am going to have an early dinner today
not entirely sure what i'm doing
i know i'm missing some pink vegetables
so i might have to have radish again
but let me show you guys what i have
right now this super
uh long fish sausage made with
fish paste as you can see in the
ingredients here pink peppercorns
pink salt then we have the salmon flakes
that i bought that are more like
a coral pink kind of like my shirt and
then we have this really cool sakura
powder this is how they normally serve
it
on rice i haven't had this in a long
time but it's also a type of fish flake
it's like kind of sweet and savory and
it's a very pretty
pink color and then we have these korean
rice cakes
i know they usually use like natural
food coloring
to add some color to their rice cakes i
think there's like some kind of filling
in there that's kind of sweet but
i'm missing carbs really not entirely
sure how
it's going to go down but i'll probably
pan fry
this sausage and try to pair up the rice
cake with the seasoning we have
yeah tada it's definitely
pink let me try to cut it up it smells
kind of fishy which makes sense because
this is fish paste
so the sausages are done i'm going to
bring back the radish that we had
earlier
so i'm just going to cut it and put it
on top of the sausages just gonna repeat
these steps
the rest of the ingredients i don't
really need to cook
like the salmon's cooked the rice cakes
are cooked i'm just going to throw them
all together
into the final plate i hope you guys are
ready for this
here is our super pink dish
so you can see the sprinkled on sakura
on the rice cakes
the radish the fish sausage and i put
the salmon flakes in the middle
so i think visually it's pretty
appetizing but
i don't actually know the combinations
work for drinks i found this kombucha
it's pink because of the guava puree
that's in it
let's give it a try that's a bite
the fish sausage is a very interesting
texture it has less of a bite than what
i'm used to
kind of reminds me of those like little
fish sausages that we used to eat as a
kid
so now i'm going to eat the rice cake
with a little sakura on top
actually with the sakura powder it's
pretty good there
is sort of like a sweet filling inside i
think it's like sugar and peanuts which
isn't pink so i'm gonna try and nibble
around it my roommate thinks i'm crazy
for trying to eat this without the
filling
i'm gonna try the sakura powder as is
actually it's so interesting the first
bite is sweet
and then it becomes savory you can
definitely taste the fish in there
but also a lot of sugar a little bit of
kombucha oh it smells
so nice i love guava and i was really
sad this time that i wasn't able to find
pink guava
oh that's so good i never even knew that
this was available
i know you guys wanted me to try eating
something else that wasn't
pasta so here i am i see you
i always end up playing with my food
really fill it up to the room with pink
that's so good i guess it makes sense
because this normally goes on rice but
wow that combination was unexpectedly
good
i really like that i'm going to finish
up here and then
gonna finish off the day with a dessert
i'm honestly so excited about this
cute packaging aside i think it just
comes in like the perfect portion size
strawberry milk bars
it's really just like strawberry milk
but frozen in strawberry milk i also
think pink foods was
pretty difficult it was more of a
struggle to maintain a balanced meal
somehow we managed to make it through
the day i hope you guys enjoyed
let me know in the comments below what
color you want to see next
and see you guys next time
hey everyone this is inca today i'm
filming a very very special episode for
you guys
for this video i will be eating only
clear foods for 24 hours
all right so here we go this is the
episode i'm actually
in tokyo japan right now that's the
beautiful tokyo tower
so i know after having done some
research that japan actually has a lot
of clear and translucent foods so i am
going to sort of include that
under the umbrella of clear foods today
i don't want to just
be eating and drinking water all day i
am actually currently walking to the
supermarket i have a list of items that
i want but i'm also just going to check
out what they have
at the store so really hoping this works
out
sugar candy i think you can eat it just
like this
never seen this before but this is like
almost like it's like clear sesame oil
i don't know what it is but i'll figure
it out this is clear
i feel like this daikon could come in
handy i'm not sure why it's clear
though it works liquid sugars
they're completely transparent i'm at
this matcha place but i found this
clear
[Music]
i know they become translucent uses salt
candy
i'm on my way to the soy sauce specialty
store that my friends at tasty japan
told me about
i am super excited because apparently
they have over 100 types of soy sauce so
can't wait to find this amazing clear
soy sauce
[Music]
so you get to sample it and i just tried
some and it tastes exactly like normal
soy sauce so i
am shook morning everyone so it is now
daytime here in tokyo i am definitely
still jet lagged
you guys know how normally i would eat
fruits for breakfast so there's a couple
of fruits that
are kind of like clear and translucent
but apparently these types of fruits are
not that common here
in tokyo i was not able to find any of
them so
i'm afraid i won't be able to eat fruit
this time around i know it's not the
best way to start the challenge
but i am also a little bit sick so
one cup of water was what i was going to
drink anyways
not my proudest moment i'm really sorry
breakfast today is a little bit
disappointing
but we do have a lot of really cool
interesting things lined up for the rest
of the day now i'm going to go back to
packing some things up i've got a bunch
of videos to shoot at the tasty
studio space today so um i'll see you
guys there
i am ready and on my way to work
thought i would treat myself because i
only had water this morning so i wanted
to
try that yuzu salt candy i bought here
it is
it's super clear i guess i'm just
curious because it says
there's salt in here too so oh yeah
that's really good you do actually taste
the specks of salt in there too
i just got like a pocket of one and i
really like it the salt probably helps
bring the sweetness out i don't think
you can ever really go wrong with
handmade candy this is exactly what i
needed so i made it to the office
i got lost a couple times i actually
took the wrong train this morning but
i'm here at
tasty japan getting ready to make a
clear lunch i don't really know how this
is going to go down at the supermarkets
there was a lot of things a lot more
things than you probably expected
because i wasn't expecting to find half
as many things as i did i think the
biggest challenge here
is to make it into not just an edible
meal but like a
a tasty meal or a meal that is really
good
let's just see what we have to work with
we have a lot of stuff here
we have rice wrappers we probably see
this the most when we're eating i think
vietnamese cuisine clear soy sauce i'm
super excited to play with this some
form
of substitute for sugar rice vinegar i
was trying to find white vinegar
but this is what they had in the tasty
kitchen white sesame oil that i've never
seen usually sesame oil is a dark brown
i would say
pickled daikon because they've been
pickled they are much more translucent
mung bean vermicelli i think i grew up
eating this
quite a bit two types of sashimi i don't
know what kind of fish they are
so we're gonna ask a red
to help this is a madai and this is a
hiram
it's kind of chewy and this one is
kawahi there isn't like a specific way
to eat it with the
soy sauce and uh wasabi i can work with
that maybe
thank you i don't think i've even ever
seen this before
super translucent you can almost see
through it i'm not gonna be able to use
the tuna in the middle because it's not
clear i think what i'm gonna do is kind
of cook the noodles cut up the daikon
marinate the sashimi a little bit wrap
them up with this
we have a bunch of sauces so i think i
can play around with that a little bit
and we can take it from there sweet
savory sour umami maybe try to make a
sauce
using these different condiments
starting with this
clear soy sauce i feel like if you
covered this up and i didn't know what
color it was i would have totally
thought it was just
normal soy sauce
because it's clear i think i like forget
that
it's actually really salty vinegar
this doesn't smell like anything right
now but
oh i kind of want to taste it it tastes
just like simple syrup so
i think we're on the right track sugar
sesame oil
this is just a clear sauce and taste it
a little bit
i feel like it's a little on the sweeter
side so i'm going to add a little bit
more soy
and a little more sesame oil
yeah i think that works now that i have
this marinade
i can try to marinate them this is what
it looks like
as much as i want there to be wasabi you
can't use it because it's green
you guys see that this is the fish oh
wow
crazy fish these are all safe to eat raw
and that's why we're doing this put
these in there
whoa hard to believe that this is in
water
gonna set that aside this is what the
vermicelli looks like
it's actually translucent and not white
gonna go ahead and toss that in
you can't even really see the noodles in
there because it's so clear
but here are the noodles
just going to rinse the noodles really
quick i think i've got most of the
things prepped it's time to do some
wrapping
this is what they look like it's
literally just a clear sheet if you
wanted to pixelate your face this is one
way to do it right now it's kind of hard
so all you have to do is put it in warm
water just a few seconds
so you see how it goes in i think that's
good
and now it's even clearer than before a
lot floppier too
so i'm going to set that down here it's
also a lot stickier
now fish on here
i'm going to sauce this a little bit i
think just with some soy sauce and
sesame oil
[Music]
now to put some of these add
a little bit of daikon just for extra
flavor
and texture
okay this is our first wrap
it looks really cool it's kind of like a
cocoon of sort
gonna make a couple more of these and
then let's serve it up
this is it these are our clear
spring rolls you can see the vermicelli
the fish
i will say that it's a little more
opaque now there's a lot of things here
that aren't completely like transparent
they clear in a more translucent type of
way and when you put all those elements
together
i think i guess they do appear a little
more white on camera i just have some
soda water
this is our clear meal i'm just gonna go
right in for it
really don't know what to expect
[Music]
there's a lot of flavors going on i have
to say i think the marinade actually
worked out pretty well
and because the daikon's pickle the
sweetness really adds a lot to it but
i'm really confused i'm gonna try that
again
now you can see the inside it probably
just looks like
really bland food in a way almost say it
would be a very healthy way
to have a meal considering what it looks
like and what it tastes like i think you
would be pleasantly surprised this is to
be pretty quick for me to finish
but i actually also have a dessert for
this meal i know usually it comes after
dinner
but i think i actually found enough
things so
i am going to bring in dessert after i
finish it up really quickly i was really
looking forward to this
this is called the kuzu mochi so this is
actually a super popular
traditional snack in japan like you know
how mochi is typically made of rice this
one's made out of kazuko which is
another type of starch
mochi is usually white this one
is actually more of a translucent
color this is usually served with
soybean powder
and a type of sweet syrup but in my case
today
we will not be using these for obvious
reasons
in its place i have actually bought this
syrup oh i'm gonna scoop a bite out so
you guys can see
so whoa
now that's satisfying so this is kind of
the
texture we're looking at it's very
jiggly you can see the spoon through
this
i'm gonna take a bite without putting
syrup first
it's already a little bit sweet oh it
almost looks like a raindrop cake
it's so jelly like
i feel like i might have had it before
because i've never actually eaten it as
is so this is super cool really treating
myself here today i have a lot to work
on while i'm here so i'm
going to wrap this up really quickly
and then get back to work so i am taking
a small break from work to actually work
on the raindrop cake that i want to have
for dinner
i think it takes some time to set in the
fridge so
i'm gonna prepare it now and then
hopefully be able to bring it home
oh but before that i wanted to try a
candy this is maltose candy don't have
you guys seen this before the last time
i saw it actually was when i was doing
um
dragonbeard's candy i'll be eating it as
is just like this little guy here i
think i need a toothpick maybe
the struggle is real oh it's so sticky
it's not always this clear
this is super clear i've seen this being
served on streets before
yo
yeah the perfect glob of
sugar i'm just playing with my food
again
oh there you go look at that do you want
this okay
here's my house so sweet wait i'm gonna
show you
this is like what kids eat festival or
sunday
it's so good but it's also so much sugar
now that snack time is over now that i
have sugar in my hair
i'm gonna get back to the raindrop cake
i'm just using the recipe from tasty
japan i'm gonna link you guys to the
recipe i'm using in the description box
below this is actually the same pot they
use in the video so
i can't go wrong with that
that's done
gonna work a little bit more now all
right guys so change of plans
i know i said i was gonna go home but
it's already dark out it gets dark
really
early here it's like already past dinner
time
and i'm really hungry so i'm just going
to make dinner here since i have all the
ingredients with me anyways i was
thinking of making something fairly
quick
i also consulted with red beforehand to
make sure i wasn't doing
anything too bizarre with the
ingredients here condiments aside we
really only have three things
these cooked bean sprouts bean sprouts
normally aren't that
translucent but after you cook them they
become
pretty see-through over here we have
what they call
tokuro ten i really hope i am saying
that right
this is again one of those things that
is very common here
in japan it is actually made from
seaweed or algae
and then we have these little baby
fishies called cheetah soup it actually
says right here
that it's meant to be consumed raw so
that is also super interesting i
actually think i have this yesterday at
a restaurant
you guys recognize the sugar substitute
from earlier and the clear soy sauce
sake and meeting they're both just like
pretty common cooking line i'm
probably going to combine all this to
make a sauce let's make this work
we have the clear soy sauce first
meeting sake
sugar normally i can kind of see how
much i want based on
like the color of the mixture because
everything is clear it's kind of trippy
just add a little bit of a taste it's
really hard to know
how much that of anything when it just
look at how clear that looks
it's like i'm just boiling water
bringing this to the stove top reduce it
a little bit
meanwhile i'm gonna chop this up there's
a lot of water in this so i'm gonna pour
that out
oh it's so clear it's actually already a
noodle form
i couldn't even tell from the packaging
whoa
this is so interesting
wow
i don't really think it smells like
anything but the texture of it like a
little softer than gelatin doesn't taste
like gelatin though it's a clear fish
isn't that insane seafood they actually
start out translucent it's just that
after we cook it it becomes opaque
this is what we have this might look a
little bit terrifying because you can
actually see the little fishies but i
also grew up eating like
little fishes like this with rice
usually it's cooked i've never had them
raw like this i'm excited to try it the
last thing to do really is just to
drizzle on the sauce that i made i'm
just gonna cool it
and then pour it over this i am now
ready
for dinner i haven't added the sauce yet
this is
what the sauce ended up looking like
it's still very much clear
can you guys still see me through it
there you have it it's a clear bowl
of noodles and fish
and vegetables it turned out pretty
clear i bet when this video first
started you guys had no idea what to
expect
this is probably the last thing you had
in mind this is wild oh
awesome here it is i've heard of clear
cola here but
i didn't actually expect to find it i
really want to start this meal off by
drinking this yeah it even smells like
coca-cola i'll try it it kind of tastes
a little bit more like cola candy cola
tasting products
it tastes like that this is crazy all
right so now for the main
course apparently there are many ways to
enjoy this the packaging actually came
with a sweet sauce but
you can eat it sweet or savory let's try
this
the sauce turned out really good and the
little fishies are
like little pockets of umami sprinkled
through i actually really like the fish
for people who are not a fan of like a
more
slimier texture you probably wouldn't
like it but
it's like sashimi and then the bean
sprouts are a nice crunch i think the
sauce i made was
a variation of teriyaki you wouldn't
expect to see teriyaki in this color
this is still the coolest thing ever so
i'm gonna slowly work on this
and then we can finally get to dessert
this is it this is the
moment of truth let's see if i was able
to do it
shall we you just
i wasn't even able to slowly do it but
here it is oh my god
i did it it's so beautiful
wow i have never made a raindrop cake
before i know it's just water and sugar
and there's no reason to freak out but
so excited to
eat it i have my server from earlier
oh that's so cool super excited i'm just
gonna dig right in you guys
wow the flavor really is just um sugar
and water but
the texture is so pleasing
i know this sounds crazy but you can
feel how
jiggly it is as you're eating it
this is so great this is the best thing
to end on it's super refreshing
i feel like i'm getting at least two
cups of my egg cups of water per day
so i actually made two raindrop cakes
for safety and
this one turned out even more amazing
this challenge honestly
i thought it would be pretty much
impossible i thought i'd be
drinking water that's it i can't stop
eating this i'm sorry
i should stop i think as i was shopping
around here i found
so many more things than i thought there
would be that kind of blew my mind a
little bit it's always so amazing to see
the different kinds of food from
different cultures and like
how when you're in different places
there's just
so many more things to discover this
challenge was actually
pretty insightful it gave me this
opportunity to try out
different things like things maybe
outside of my comfort zone maybe things
that i've never even
thought of trying before and felt like i
learned a lot from it i hope you guys
did too now that i've finally done clear
foods
let me know what else i should be doing
whether it's a different color
maybe a different challenge i'm open to
any ideas you might have
so let me know until then
see you guys hey guys this is inca
and this time i will only be eating blue
foods
for 24 hours this is probably the most
requested one color food challenge so i
have been doing a lot of research but
unfortunately there really are just not
that many naturally blue foods in the
world
and a lot of the ones that i was hoping
to find i couldn't find them here in new
york
apparently the blue lobster and i don't
know if this is true but the odds of
catching one is like 1
in 200 million but with that being said
i will try to find most if not all of
the remaining blue foods
and this time i am starting with the
internet i feel like a lot of the things
that i want to find
i might not be able to find in store but
i know that they have them
online just to be safe you guys first
off we have this butterfly pea flower
tea
drink places use it to make
like blue themed drinks i also found
this blue magic powder so the blue magic
powder
is a dietary supplement essentially it's
spirulina extract this type of blue
green algae that has
a lot of health benefits i also got this
blue
cornmeal i thought this would be really
fun for us to work with
next thing as per usual i am going to
head to
i think at least two grocery stores just
to explore our options
and see what we can find that's blue
but i'm pretty sure that's not natural
coloring so we're not gonna go for it
found this kombucha
that is a beautiful blue they use blue
spirulina to make it blue
which are the qualifiers
[Music]
super interesting i have never had these
before so
excited to try it good morning everyone
it
is a gloomy day today in
new york it is raining outside which i
guess
is on brand since today is a blue foods
day
i am excited but also nervous about
today because
there isn't too much to work with but
i'm gonna try to make the most out of it
for breakfast i found this juice shop
this juice place that
actually sells blue magic smoothie bowls
it basically looks like an acai bowl but
blue
so i think i'm gonna head over there and
buy us some breakfast
i will check back in with you guys when
i'm on the way i am walking to the juice
shop now
hopefully i find what i'm looking for it
would make this day start off a lot
easier
i just ordered this bowl
i bought my smoothie bowl i also bought
this drink
they both use blue spirulina as coloring
so i'm excited to try it i am going to
head back to the office now though
so i can sit down and eat this properly
made it to the office
there's a lot of blue i think because
the blueberries were kind of smooshed so
they're a lot more purple here
usually for their protein bows you can
order like three toppings
i basically said i wanted three servings
of blueberries because everything else
they weren't blue
opening this up oh my goodness look at
this
blue but oh wow the blueberries are
definitely still frozen so i'm just
gonna mix it together
smells really good there's a lot of
things that went into this but the blue
spirulina
really did just make it into this like
super blue looking bowl i'm just gonna
go right for it
big bite
brain freeze i think everything else in
this bowl right now kind of covers
however the spirulina tastes
but i like it and obviously the frozen
blueberries are really good i will say
though that the fact that it is blue
does kind of come off as
intimidating it's kind of crazy to think
that this is all natural we've come to
associate like blue with
just anything that's unnatural i have to
run to a meeting now
and i'm curious to know what everybody
else is going to think what do you have
can i show you my breakfast
it smells good though smell it oh it
does smell good it's a color day
blue it's a blue color day
[Music]
it is a pretty color all right i'll be
here
the meeting is now over people said it
smelled nice
i actually really like this shade of
blue even though yeah it does
look more like paint than actual food
this is super filling which
is really nice actually i've really
thought that today i'd be starving this
is definitely
sustenance we're off to a great start
gonna clean up a little bit
and then go work and i'll see you guys
for lunch
we are back here in the tasty studio
it's a little weird but i feel like i'm
still really full from breakfast
there was a lot of ingredients packed
into that bowl a lot of nutrients which
is probably a good thing based on what
you guys saw when i went grocery
shopping
there weren't actually that many things
most of it was like drinks
or powder but i think i have enough to
work with
so i'm gonna show you guys what i have
for lunch we have red cabbage
i found this hack that can turn this red
cabbage
into blue so we're going to test that
out today
purple or blue potato it goes by both
names
blue corn tacos from that taco kit i
found
blue potato chips made from naturally
blue potato we really only have four
items
but i think i can make some sort of taco
with
potato and cabbage inside i'm going to
start off by cutting up
the potatoes into bite-sized pieces to
put into the taco shell
i know right now it's super purple but
once we cook it this color will change
into a purplish blue
so be patient with me while we
continue to do this got my potatoes
tossed this
in i think i'll check on this after i
finish cooking the cabbage the hack i
found was that
if you add baking soda to red cabbage it
becomes blue
i'm planning on adding a bit of baking
soda when i'm sauteing
the red cabbage and hopefully that will
turn it into blue cabbage grabbing a
blue spatula
toss this in i'm just going to cook it a
little bit before adding anything else i
want it to become a little more soft
you see how the colors change slightly
this is what we were originally working
with
and this is the color it's become
potatoes are pretty much ready so i will
take them out there it is
our blue potatoes now that the cabbage
is
a little softer i am going to add some
baking soda
do you guys see that instant color
change it's definitely a
like aqua blue color i'm gonna turn the
stove
off i think at this point it really is
the plating
this is what we have there's three
different colors of blue going on
there's that really beautiful blue
coming from the potatoes the greenish
blue with the red cabbage plus baking
soda the taco shell
is more of a grayish blue
the blue potato chips kind of turned out
more a vibrant purple which i wasn't
expecting
i guess that just means it retained more
of its like raw purple color
honestly not bad at all if you see the
potatoes it's very very soft the cabbage
is a little more interesting i feel like
the baking soda definitely changes the
flavor
a little bit slimier textures not sure
if i would normally do that but color
wise
you can see that they all kind of blend
together blue is my favorite color
though
so i am all for it remember how i also
bought an extra drink that features blue
magic
and electrolytes which it says right
here and i wanted to show you guys what
blue magic is
because i was so curious to know what it
was spirulina extract for healthy joints
i'm gonna pour some of this out
whoa instantly you can see how blue it
is
this is crazy this is completely natural
believe it or not
it's such a pretty vibrant blue super
pigmented
it does smell a little funky i have to
say fishy but i guess since it does come
from
algae that would make a lot of sense
yeah i do not get any of that blue magic
flavor there's also lime juice lemon
juice maple syrup in here
it makes sense that it's covered by the
other things
all natural gatorade honestly i think
they pretty much just taste like regular
potato chips just like how the blue
potatoes i had
it's just that it is this blue
i almost said to full i've said blue too
many times today it's really just
visually different it's nice
sometimes to you know add a little bit
of color to your place all right so i'm
just gonna be here
finishing up my lunch not sure if i'm
actually gonna be snacking anything
later i'm
feeling pretty full surprisingly
remember how i told you guys
that i wouldn't have a snack today so
apparently
oops gotta let myself in first
apparently
alvin said he got me a small dessert
so i am
taking a break from work to go see what
it is
the upper shelf of the fridge in a blue
bag
[Music]
excited this is the box everything is
blue super on brand
there's a note i don't know how to make
macarons so i got you a blue one from
the store
they said that the color is natural but
he forgot the flavor
and that he ate the rest of the macarons
he bought
classic this is so pretty
i love this i wonder if it's also the
blue magic
powder that everybody's been using
almost like a fruity sweetness which was
exactly the type of thing i needed
wow thanks alvin appreciate it yay
all right time for me to go back to work
now i'll be meeting with alvin
and he brought back some snacks and this
this is blue
this was made with what butterfly pea
flour amazing i'm taking off the coconut
sugar
yay
[Music]
it's good it just tastes like sticky
rice i think it's because i didn't eat
the sugar wow this is already more
desserts than i thought i would have
great stuff i'm back home so there's two
things i really want to do
one is dinner of course and the other is
dessert i know i had a little dessert
snack earlier but
i really wanted to try and make a blue
dessert myself
but first things first let's start off
with dinner we pretty much
only have two things one is the blue
cornmeal which i plan on using to make
some cornbread
and then we have some blue corn tortilla
chips i do have some left
over a blue red cabbage from earlier so
i'm going to
eat that with this meal too just to get
my veggies in i think
playing with this would be quite fun i
would say it's like a very faint
blue i already got started on making the
cornbread
batter this is what it looks like now
this is pretty much the color of the
cornmeal we bought so
i'm just gonna put this now into the
baking pan
and then pop it in the oven
while i'm waiting for the cornbread to
bake i am going to get started on
dessert so the dessert i wanted to do
today is
pretty much just um the butterfly pea
flour tea but in jelly form i really
hope this works
they really are just flower petals it's
like an ugly herbal smell
oh did you guys see that i love how it
instantly turned blue this
is so cool i am
in awe so i'm just gonna let this steep
for a while it's been about
15 minutes and i wanted to show you guys
what the butterfly pt looks like look at
that
it's so blue i love it i can't believe
this is natural coloring
right now i'm going to combine this with
some more water and then we're gonna add
in the agar agar
and then we can pour it out into the
molds so now that the jelly is in the
fridge
the cornbread is pretty much done i just
took it out of the oven and i am super
excited
if you guys take a look at this you can
see the blue peeking through
it just smells amazing in here so
i am super well i'm like salivating
that's why i can't even talk i am really
really looking forward to this
i'm just going to let this cool and then
next time you see me
i will have this plated and we'll be
ready to eat
excited the meal is completed
here is the final reveal this is my meal
right here there's like different shades
of blue going
on purplish blue the cornbread it's like
a little darker than the normal
cornbread you can see the blue cornmeal
inside it's not like
that super vibrant blue you would expect
the blue cabbage from
earlier i feel like after it sits for a
while it becomes
even more blue it's almost like a
turquoise kind of blue over here
i have some blue ice that i made earlier
they are super pretty i'm super proud of
these
i made this blue ice with some black
goji berries
this is what the black goji berries look
like it also gives that like vibrant
blue color
i have this kombucha super super blue
drink
it has kombucha in it coconut water
ginger juice and blue magic
which i feel like has been featured very
heavily
this episode yeah oh
wow
now that's pretty epic percy jackson
would be so proud
this is incredible wait you guys have to
look at this
it's like solid shapes of blue in a
sea of blue tastes really good
again i don't taste the blue magic
portion because it was combined with
ginger juice it's the ginger
that stands out the most even though
it's completely blue
it tastes just like a lemon and ginger
kombucha which is amazing
i want to start with the cornbread it
really did smell so amazing
all i did really was just following a
basic cornbread recipe but substituting
regular cornmeal with blue cornmeal the
blue is very very subtle
i'm going to go right for it
[Music]
this is really good i don't know if
there is
too much of a difference between
cornbread made with regular cornmeal and
blue cornmeal
but i do feel like the flavor in this
one is a little
nuttier i really like this cornbread i
only cut three slices here but i'm
pretty sure i'll be eating
all of it because i'm hungry just want
to show you guys this cabbage again
it kind of looks like seaweed at this
point and i have the blue corn tortilla
chips
like they're pretty popular it almost
tastes a little bit sweeter and it feels
grainier which i kind of like i like it
when
chips have like different textures it's
not as like
smooth and refined i'm a big fan of blue
corn apparently i didn't know that until
now if you haven't had a chance to try
blue corn tortilla chips
maybe try and grab a bag next time when
you're buying chips and salsa i feel
like you guys would like this too
i'm very pleased with this dinner i am
going to finish this off give it a few
hours before
we dig into dessert i finally finished
cleaning up
i am ready for dessert so i took the
jelly that i made earlier out
and they came out pretty cool hold on
let me show you guys ta-da i added in
some blueberries for decoration
also i love the shape of these molds
it's the same one that i used in my
other video where i made edible jewelry
and so these
came out super pretty i'm gonna try one
now
whoa how cool is that color it's a very
comforting shade of blue
and this again was all just the doing of
the butterfly pt
there is no artificial food coloring in
here at all
because it's agar agar it's like a clean
cut there's a little bit of sugar
but for the most part it still tastes
like the butterfly pt
it's like sweetened herbal tea and a
blueberry to end it off
so that is the end of my blue color food
challenge
i hope you guys enjoyed it as always i
had a lot of fun
putting these creative dishes together
for you also this time i will be linking
some of the things that i used in the
description box below if you guys
ever want to try this challenge yourself
definitely if you make any one color
food dishes
send them to me i would love to see them
it's always so fun seeing what you guys
can do
now that i've finally done blue foods
let me know what other color you want me
to do
other than that i will see you guys in
the next video
[Music]
[Applause]
bye
[Applause]
you